welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on cell biology of
diseases it's my pleasure to introduce
to you dr. Marie Christine Berlin head
associate for the genetic engineering
and model validation department and the
Institute Clinique Dilla cerise since
2013 she has implemented the CRISPR
Castine technology and now most of the
models are generated through this
approach for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr. Berlin's keynote presentation is
titled CRISPR cast 9 genome editing in
Mouse and rap the Fenneman ICS
experience
my name is Antonina Polanco and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Marie Christine
Berlin I will now turn the presentation
over to her hi everybody I'm happy to
present you today the fenomena ICS
experience just to tell where we are
because I think we were Chris Christmas
since a while but we have we are the
French Mouse clinic here and I'm head of
the genetic engineering and genome
editing service where we do all this
work about generating new Mouse
we are part of philomene which which is
a three centers are related in phenomena
that's the left panel and we also part
of cell media and that's on the back you
can see the center and the East ICS most
clinic in Osborn your husband's house is
on the Left panel on the bottom okay
let's go no to CRISPR to CRISPR what we
can do with CRISPR I'm just with whisper
what you can do CRISPR simply what it
does is generating a double strand break
then when we introduce Christine sell
all CRISPR is doing is generating a
double strand break and of course
afterwards what can occur is after the
double strand break the cell doesn't
like to have DNA that is cut and then it
will kind of three blue this DNA and
that's club called in one Americas and
joining when there are some mistakes
then they can be in this or small
insertion in this case but what we are
really interested in is definitely
something that is a specific correction
and that's done when we inject or
electroplate or introduced last name
with CRISPR with the donor DNA this
donor DNA can introduce limitation we
want under it's possible to use those
single stranded RNA or double strands
doing dohno DNA and this event is
definitely in event that we would like
to emphasize here and we are not so
interested in the generation of
initiative but in generating precise
event okay there at phenomenal yes we
are using CRISPR class nine not only to
generate most lines but also to
regenerate front lines because CRISPR
works on everything of course most we
are also yourself but here in the first
ensign in Sun in instance I will show
you what we do with mouse and rat
embryos because we introduce CRISPR cast
nine wins or whistle to the no DNA in
the
embryos in the one cell embryos or by
microinjection
or electroporation in the mouse we have
another approach which is yes cells but
in the rat it's the only way to obtain
genetically engineered tract I have to
say that we are also part at phenomena
assessed like many centers in the world
you can see that on the top right panel
we are part of the npc's
and length see the aim of the LPC 2 is
to generate knockout of all the protein
coding gene in order to do a high-speed
phenotyping pipeline on all these lines
that are generated as part of this
consortium we are generating we have
generated quite a few lines knockout
lines directly using crystal cos 9 and
the approach that we take here is
deleting a critical exon this exon when
it's not there anymore will generate the
deletion of the same X and will generate
a frameshift and lead to a premature
stop codon and solely to knock out of
course we also do these know called
Judas collaborators and I just want to
emphasize here that it's really really
very efficient it was even by
microinjection we you can see here than
seven pups born after microinjection of
pre stockist nine and two pairs of guide
we have more than half of the animals
usually that have the deletion and that
a potency potentially interesting that
that can be bred to generate the
knockout then it is really efficient and
really cheap and then the time needed to
generate this line can be decreased to
five to six months instead of going to
more than an year going through year
sets so that's really interesting and
that's what I think that all the MPC is
taking at the moment it's fast cheap and
easy and the only drawback is also such
we only have a local Tennille and no
reporter are no constantly Annie and
then as I said just before that
generated straight knockout when you use
crystal but here I just
one to emphasize that we as part of the
NPC also we are also generating lines
through yourselves because there was a
whole pipeline law firm of of people
that were generating yourself with a
much more complex allele and this
complex allele is no comes first because
each introduced is a legacy after before
a critical eggs on which stops the
expression of the gene and after when
once you're in the line you can read
this line with a 3d heater line in order
to obtain condition and local train or
knockout line by removing the critical
exon then this allele is still really
highly valuable and we continue to
produce this most line because as soda
as a normal scientist when they are
really interested in a gene genes they
don't only want to have local talent but
to more valuable and units that can be
looking for a consonant new coat and
then they can breed a language their pre
the preferred Creek okay and just to say
here I just add that most of the
conditional alleles that are available
at the moment are coming from the NPC
because we are generated in this
consumption more lies more conditionally
lives than in the whole world
besides consortium and it's the same for
the reporter allele then the workforce
is from this consortium is quite
impressive and it's really believable
and then you can go and see on the
website I that he stated on the top of
the slide there are many interesting
data on this on this website go and see
there but know what what I want to
emphasize here also is that we can also
generate no coaching Watson that works
really well as well as adding most
definitely by injecting just two pairs
of guide RNA we discussed nine into an
egg and targeting a critical exon is
critical example generate the frame
shift we can generate knockouts and that
see slides are really nice
I really like to show them because you
can see here it's our collaborator that
give them this slide you can see the
dystrophin that is really nicely
expressed in white type whereas in front
doors you can see that the animal that
is the mountain in the first instance
are mosaics and only some cells
expressing this proteins and it's a
really nice way to sleep here again it's
interesting because often the examples
that are shown about the efficiency of
CRISPR are used on this model of of
myopathy because this gene is roofing is
located on the X chromosome this means
that when you walk with male it's much
more easy than when working with CMS
where you have two alleles to targets
both from ISM in males added from the X
chromosome you have only one I need to
target and here is the genotyping that
you perform fo under therefore it smells
a tree Jena tides first and you could
see only one allele is again when it
looked almost hemizygous and the animal
named one two numbered 1 to 14 RDS 1 and
you can see that all the females had the
deletion which show that it's really
efficient and is lined by still not
published but it's technically the first
position mr. anchovy model in rat and
will be certainly really valuable to
study in the model in moving lives ok
know about conditional knockouts and
Crispus then in my physician of opened
often people that come and ask me can
you do conditional code really fast and
cheap and that's of course what
everybody would like to have because
conditional is very conditional
knockouts are really valuable model to
understand the the role of the genes in
certain when bread with some create
delete or lines then agency or not GG
that's a question then to remind you I
don't know if you followed an older
literature but in 2013 at the very
beginning of CRISPR the one state
coming out saying from who don't finish
not saying that everything will be
simple they sure that everything is
efficient it's possible to target three
genes together to get easily
conditionals but all what they did here
they were analyzing formulas and what
happens happened afterwards it's that a
lot of people tried to reproduce what
was on the paper some some things were
reproducible and some other less and
that was the case of conditional and in
2019 this year a paper came out from the
Murphy and a lot of different teams that
says that it's not seem so simple to
obtain conditional knockouts simply
because if you use two as a sedan with
both looks facade on both side and the
guide RNA on both side you will get only
very few successful project and the
success rate was less than 1% that's
really bad and why is it so bad and
that's certainly the reason why I didn't
want to begin to try to get conditioned
and the host using this method here is
to single-stranded the oligonucleotide
and that's again the case the desired
outcome is less than 1% as I said but
what you will get you will get a lot
film website once I don't film the other
side in this on both sides elation and
all these things can occur because you
generated over strong break and you want
to have some specific recommendations
that occurs and when you generate two
double strand braids at the size of
postdocs besides you would like to
introduce you generate in most of the
cases but elation because it's two
different breaks and that generates the
deletion then it is not so easy from
taken condition and occult and of course
no there was paper there was his paper
in 2015 and 17 saying is saying that the
solution would be single-stranded DNA
rather than double-stranded DNA and
there was his paper there from the RFP
again and they said that in this case it
will work
here I want to show you one project
that's all pretty well in how our hand
saying it's not really obvious because
we observe a little bit the same kind of
things that were was observed by all the
people that tried to do conditional
lookout but with a single-stranded don't
know DNA instead of two single-stranded
illegal to insert locks beside it will
work better and that's what your thing
then first on the top the drawing of the
scheme of the zoo experiment you want if
we use two guides that are called gia 67
and G at 73 and they were micron ejected
with the single-stranded DNA and cast
nine and that's the number that you
obtain we obtain 34 pups and we got one
purpose that had bought both blocks P
side and that was done by deforming
official from inside to outside of the
constructs then we were sure it was at
the locus we also obtained one fondo one
animal that had a nice deletion but we
were so certain that was already
described and that was fine indeed in
between we obtained abstain for animals
that had only five Pandavas beside and
three animals occurred only knew three
prong looks decent but it's possible to
ten which we won because we bred
Etobicoke spots that had both those
looks P on the same Anil
we showed that indeed the well they were
on the same allele which is important
not on opposite allele on different
chromosomes and when we bred them you
can hear cv90 a genotyping you can see
that we obtained homozygous tops with a
green arrow and that indeed that's true
because even when we perform the PCR
from outside to outside you can really
see a nice little shift and we validated
that everything is fine and that is
really important
we validate that by thousand words
seeing that you have only one insertion
and that's with an internal probe one
insertion of our
single-stranded DNA
and we also used token digital PCR we
put a probe as an internal probe the
smaller probe by the oaken disturb you
sir and we have only two cookies by the
pallet that was great and on the other
ideas we were able also to fully
sequence all what we introduced and what
can be done juris receives 20 DNA I
believe it is the case on any project is
that you can introduce mutations that
you don't master and that's why perhaps
double-stranded DNA is a better solution
because there will be less mutation
there no next point I want to emphasize
here point mutations that is pretty
simple and works really very well by
micro injection or electroporation we
had plenty of successful project the
only limitation is dominant less than
allele and in this case it's annoying
because the fondle will die that we
obtained after my two injection or
electroporation of the cast 9 guide and
the donor DNA that can be a pain and
here I'm going to show you one example
because the German one example of muda
that we tried to reproduce it's a model
for as I know disease it was a human in
relation of the rat ATP it wasn't right
and we wanted to you an eyes the three
amino acids that are in green here and
to introduce this mutation we choose a
guide at this time it was one of our
first projects such as called 78 and the
approach is on the right panel you can
see the donor DNA at the hardest
limitation and we introduced on HPA to
restriction site okay and we said we
immediately the berry in order to make
sure that when we have the correct
mutation that each one has nine one be
able to wicked then we need to imitate
the other part of the recognition
sequence also gap under such the
genotyping we obtain here you can see
not all of the fonder we're positive but
when we digest just in the PCR product
f1 f3
we could obtain
that we could see that some fundo have
the correct restriction earthside
expected and here I just want to show
you the example of the front door 9 5 3
yeah
if you focus on this one it looks
homozygous when we looked at the
chromatogram because crystal is about
pollutant eventpro's yet the coromoto
gram when you analyze fondos and even
later we spend a lot of time looking at
programs and here you can see that even
if the first petition with the hpa2 side
is very nice - it looks homozygous or
this fonder you can see that afterwards
you can see little small double peaks
and that was intriguing and even here on
the latest you can see there is a real
double peak then we bred this Fonda we
had the 3 mutation we bred this Fonda
and that's what we obtained it looked
like all of the f1 pups had the mutation
because the restriction site was there
but when we looked at the chromatogram
again we could see that only three of
these pups had the three mutations and
do those animals had only one of the
mutation that wasn't the hpa2
restriction site that's why it is really
very important to check really the
promoter run and check that everything
is correct
and in this case it was really important
then our general observation is that the
closest to the distance between the
permutation want to integrate and the
selection guide RNA coaching side is the
better we need to make sure that the
test has 9 doesn't freak out after HDR
then in the donor DNA you need to retain
all the pom all the else tRNA
recognition site in the donor fragment
if though it will work out and we can
and cricket and you will never obtain
the mutation you want it is nice when
you want to use the genotyping to
introduce the agnostic restriction site
and of course this one need to generate
a silent mutation because of course you
don't want to introduce mutation in the
code in your sequence there is one
slight risk is that introducing silent
mutation who
generate some strange splicing and that
needs to be assessed of course when you
do permutation your other outcomes are
no codes because you might get also
energy that's a small in Delta need and
if you have a deletion of something that
she's not about to blueprint you get a
knock out because it will generate a
premature stop codon and you can also
get the knock out and finally and that's
we read for every founder that you
obtain the biopsy's that we take from
this founder and begin your tale of
senior does not completely reveals the
genetic makeup of a founder we really
need to redesign money in order to make
sure that she will indeed get what she
want and by reading this advanced we
will really set up a line and be sure of
the line melting no I told you is pretty
simple to obtain point mutations that's
true but you I would like to show you a
difficult case that's the case one case
that we had unlike if it's nice to share
it because sometimes CRISPR is not it's
not so easy because you need two other
guys that can specifically and that was
a case for a point mutation we wanted to
introduce in this gene gene here Sdn 10a
and you can see here it's surrounded by
red this gene is here but besides this
gene there are some auto gene of the
same family and CN v l-l sen 11a and
when you look closer at that you can see
that when you align both sequences you
can clearly see that sequence e is for a
CSC and by a innocent and a pretty
identical then understand the limitation
that is surrounded on the top down the
lower panel you can see here that you
can choose a guy that specific because
it will also cut in SC and file a then
it's pretty complicated in this case
when something that is very specific we
tried this way then instead of
introducing
answer
and the red side here limitation because
you couldn't get a specific guide we
tried with two guides and we tried to
introduce a rotation here with guides
that we're more specific from the
audience
and unfortunately we were not successful
and this is no I want to tell you that
that was not very interesting we
couldn't get the line that's why we
decided to go through ESS and in the
last part of my talk I will respect
about ESS because we still have a very
good yourself facility and Budhia cells
but ESS can still be really helpful and
in this case it was because we were in
Bern in this case to find the guy that
was completely specific because it was
indeed intron and this guy was put at
the place of the insertion of the New
York selection for for this point
mutation and we were really easily able
to obtain many positive clones and to
validate this positive con and to obtain
general transmission then we spend a
little bit of time with crisper but
sometimes ES cells are still the correct
way because you can take a different
approach with also construct than just
senior stranded the polygon nucleotides
because something it's not possible and
you have new guys that are specific
enough in this case we are completely
sure that everything is fine and that we
are at the correct Ally and that you
haven't targeted the Sen 5a a lead that
I think is really a nice tool to still
have his ESS with CRISPR then small of
looking's just flows few slides to tell
you that that's also pretty good such
one example in this case we had to
introduce three times H a tag at the
netted yield of one gene and you can see
here the genotyping we obtained many
founders I will go pretty quickly
through the slides even some of these
founders looked almost homozygous
that found out 21 22 and that was really
nice and we very easily obtained German
transmission from this line that is
really efficient then forms for small
tags that works pretty well
then no problem with that and know one
thing that she's a little bit of
specificity or something that really
developed at phenomenas es is a
stretcher imbalance because we know a
lot of things that you can do with Swiss
Pakistan and I think that even if it's
published it's not so well known and you
need to knows and you can play and
generate much more fancy lives with
means guide Iranian cast 9 and that's
why why do we want to generate
structural white Valiant that is because
in the human there are many diseases
that are due to chromosomal aberration
there are some variable trisomies that
concern many only I would say because if
no it's less than human small small
chromosomes and mainly trisomy 21 such
as the main subject of the director of
the ISS and that's why we're interested
in this model but there are also some
humans some babies that are born with
stress on me or forms of 18 or 13 that
happens and of course there are also
many human diseases that are due to
micro deletions or micro duplications
and I saw them all here I won't spend
time to describe them all but anyways I
exist
and the other ok then we did we need
animal models to study these syndromes
and that's what we did in regenerating
new rat down syndromes Buddhists I won't
move through the way most models were
generated before CRISPR but you need to
know that they were using looks beside
it was taking three to five years to
obtain a line and I will show you here
that when we decided to go for the rat
Buddha of trisomy of human tree try to
me that's how we we proceeded
you must know at the beginning that the
human chromosome 21 is a small
chromosome Putin on the left panel here
has two main synteny domains and domain
that contains the same gene and this on
what Ramon eleven and on rat chromosome
20 okay then if
duplicate the domain that are on rat
chromosome 11 we will have a model that
is close to trisomy of chromosome
trisomy of human chromosome 21 for this
region and the same for white clothes on
20 okay then that's what how we
proceeded and that's an example of this
region the first region here that his
own human chromosome 11 and here you can
see this region is already quite big
it's either 3.6 Megabass and this is a
project we undertook we undertook this
approach again like doing knockouts we
used pairs of guide RNA simply because
research if one guy doesn't cut well do
one will cut and as you want to delete
something that is not it would work and
we design primer all over the regions to
be able to check if real scenes
inversion duplications or deletions okay
and in the case of this region here such
is a region that is synthetic to human
chromosome 21 that's what we were what
we did we obtained animals we couldn't
see anything by junction sequencing
that's why we generated we order the
prompts for droga digital t-shirt Kezia
and that's what cbs13 brew you can see
it in blue here and with their from dope
register PCR on some responders and you
can see here on the left panel here you
can see the genotyping the dope a
digital PCR results of the first fondo
we obtained and you can see here that we
have one founders in which we could see
the deletion at least of CBS but it was
most probably the whole region was the
meeting because CBS is in the middle of
this region and as we couldn't see
duplications because that's more than we
are looking for we bred the animal such
where that occurred here 8 1 8 8 1 1 0 1
and 1/3 sorry about that
an abrasive and we were really
very pleased when we see that breathing
this fonder 8:02 we could see that in
the first liter we could see animals
that had the deletion and animals that
had the duplication that means that this
animal was nada eek it had one ally with
a deletion and one allele with a
duplication and then when bread we could
obtain all the duplication or the
deletion because after meiosis you can
only get one of jelly and that was
really nice we could obtain that and
when we checked here with different
probes the different Carozza also you
can see the gene on the top when we
checked with different doper digital
paul we can you could you could even
indeed see that the whole region wa was
all deleted or duplicated according to
the f1 animal could see and thanks to
that we could look for the junction
because you can see that sometimes we
observed that sometimes the deletion is
a little bit larger than what we expect
and then we need to search for the
junction and take oligonucleotides at
Adam but our little further than the
wind expected size since that's what was
really useful and this means we were
able to obtain the duplication and the
duration of this line very fast and in a
very fast way and it was also quite
cheap to obtain that then what did we
learn from that
such is possible to generate monotony
and transou me and more models in the
deployed context and we have generated
up to a duplication of of up to 24
megabytes and that's huge but it really
works very well and the the only problem
the only limit to this approach is to is
really little liberality all the ability
to read of the founders who sometimes
are survived because of suppose we
delete a lot of genes in some cases then
what we also learned is that sometimes
when we use primers on both sides of the
deletion sometimes we don't immediately
see what we want that I what I showed
you before because sometimes the
deletion is much larger and that's wide
open is it
this young really helps us to find those
correct animals and after we can find
the Junction's and I think both approach
Junction PCR and sequencing and open
digital PCR are really great to help us
to understand what we get and it is
really very fast because we can get a
line in six months at least the
duplication or deletion whereas before
it was taking quite a very long time
that was published and it is really
helpful you need to know that then know
how far can we get without yourself then
just to recapitulate here what you can
get it is very easy to obtain the code
in death of deletions and duplications
even groups even if duplications are
less frequent it is easy to obtain
permutation and small dad condition and
of course our CDs could obtain but it is
possible and no larger keys are still a
problem I have to say with crystal
because it is not so simple to obtain
them and we don't really know why it's
more complicated talking on a large
looking instead of a small looking's but
the mechanism are not exactly the same
that's what if you observe genome in ES
cells definitely not then easy CRISPR
can have easy CRISPR is using a
single-stranded DNA that's what I showed
you before but it's ever pawn and you
can have mistakes in the donor DNA and
that can take a lot of time to fully
validate a line because you need to be
sequence everything and here I want to
say when you do a large looking's with
crystal you need ring to check the whole
picture that's why I put this this
picture of the proble of the blind man
and the elephant don't just just look at
one thing you need to get a whole
picture and I think that you need to add
to reproduce the PCR or even better of
southern blots that will give you the
whole picture of you and Leila because
if you just do small piece yeah you
might miss some event and I really
believe that in the scientific in the
world there are many lines that people
believe they are fine because they did
only small PCR and if you look
she would look much closer you would see
you would see that everything is not
completely fine then really be careful
and look at the whole elephant at the
whole picture instead of just at one
little test that is sometimes not enough
and not to finish this little party I
want to say that there was paper coming
out for Janet for song to CHR Crispo
which seems to be really interesting and
thin this experiment seems to work
already in some labs we are testing that
at the moment at the ICS and this method
was first published in the archives on
2018 in nature biotech and he takes the
advantage of the long G to face and open
chromatin structure into cell stage
embryo okay and instead whenever you
inject into one cell stage when they
injected the s stage with a to see you
injected to the g2 stage then this
technique is supposed to work and works
in some lab with double-stranded
circular DNA in which you can completely
sequence and be sure the sequence and I
think that will help to generate
efficiently large nucleus and at the
moment we are testing that but we have
single data at the moment but I think
it's good future perhaps certainly
better than seniors from the DNA no I
just want to show you the benefits of
electroporation that we developed like a
lot of teams of course but I think it's
nice to share also in this webinar is to
tell you that electroporation is really
nice and all that our first show you my
cringe action needs some really skilled
people because you need to go into the
four nuclei some people like to inject
into cytoplasmic but you know facilities
I don't like to inject in the cytoplasm
you need to have very skilled people
whereas electroporation is much simpler
you put you your eggs your fertilized
egg in between two electrodes you purse
with square square pulse we use a nipper
21 but all the electroporation tip all
the extra Prater sewing will work
just to say first we checked by you're
using mRNA for GFP and you can see here
that it works really well you have nice
to sell embryos that are very nicely GFP
and that's what we did we tested a few
project here five project and that's the
data you think they are the same project
with electric with mild to injection
less panel or electroporation right
panel and you can really see here that
even if you obtain approximately the
same number of animals you can really
see that the number of positives that
are so Orange : are much much higher
when we use electroporation because you
have not anymore the bias of the
microinjection and that is really great
because you increase availability of the
yum breo's and then you need to inject
less embryos into into foster mother and
it is really nice
then it's really interesting for the
three are because it's really reduce and
minimize the number of animal used by
experiments and what is also really
interesting is that it really reduces
the post because we need to use less
animal
let's donors from L less foster one
muscle then electroporation is really
some things that you are using know for
all of our project then you have done
not so many but they all worked really
nicely we on average I think we don't
need to rely on more than three foster
model that's about 50 x60 electroporated
eggs to get 2 liters and in these 2
liters we have more than enough funders
to breed afterwards what is really also
very nice fidelity operation is that we
can just buy 4 of fertilizer sites from
some from John here for instance in
France we can get them and we saw them
and then we can just electroporator
suicides this virtualized all site
without having to breed animals and so
on that's really really convenient also
if you don't have too many too many
project you can just throw throws and
work on this one and of course it opens
the field it should work in any genetic
background it works also really when in
this exchange anything
or the project I show you in most other
in BC's engine is bound by one sometimes
we need to do that in jail but of course
toons who walks in by the sea and so on
and that's really nice
we also know as we are really confident
in our general electroporation what we
do know when we do not think positive we
will just do an electric version of
approximately 14 years in Rio Rossum
schuberth blast aside and check if we
have what we want and if we get what we
want we can say that afterwards after
were in contention that means that the
embryos are dying because modification
we do is less fun and that's really nice
because it it it validates the approach
and that's really nice and that's how we
do it and I have to say I thought he
made approximately the same it all works
also with heart operation we can't write
communication saying do you want need to
the double completely different approach
it really works well for hot all sides
to know another part I wanted to
emphasize here is hot on a guided by DDT
then that's another crystal toolbox and
it was quite interesting and some people
asked us we don't do that and here I
want to tell you I want to share what I
think and what we obtain doing some
tests with this RNA guided passage then
what is RNA guided by editing simply we
know that cast 9 is a wonderful protein
because you can fuse it with any protein
you want and in this case you can show
this with your Giannini's
and it still does its function when it
is with a guide RNA it will generate
this complex and the complex will
recognize the sequences that you want to
target specifically in any cell type
that's the way how it work
when we use our negative eliciting
usually the past 9 is all the last 9 or
in case cases cast night okay then that
means it is not supposed
to generate double strand break or to
generate break just supposed to sit
there and to do what I will show you the
amination and if you use sitting there -
it will change C to G okay
and that's watch it watch it watch twin
do you can under so that's what it will
do and afterwards how it does work
cytidine deaminase is great because it's
it's linked to this de Menezes could
upper back one and it has a specific
editing window as it doesn't cut it will
upper back will just modify this see the
scene the citizen that are located in
theory in this eating window that she's
not really precise but that is presented
as being an didn't video that is located
12 to 16 base pair from the panel
sequence okay if you're seated in the I
mean is the principle is exactly the
same when you lose add in india- because
but it's a little bit more complicated
because I had to choose to to domain but
still that's the way it works then how
they present that in the papers
represents that there is a real
advantage there is no need to use donor
DNA there is no double strand break so
no relation that's what I'm asking
that could be really especially
interesting for gene therapy or Salvage
education for for therapy because of
course when you use Chris podcast
everything is afraid about of targets
and an unsold and the course is that it
is not precise enough the real problem
is that in this editing window if you
use it in the laminate
if you have more than one see it can
potentially modify all the see and of
course you are limited in the mutation
you want to introduce
c OG c to t sorry
G to a according to the strand on which
you are all for the sickening diamond L
or a to G or T to see according to the
strong for the adenine DM image and also
of course if you have targets and if the
guide is recognizing another region and
you have a see also City
it could potentially also modify
something else and that's an example
that was published and its nature
biotech
you have the reference here and in this
case they use adenine DNA's you can see
here that the a can be transformed in a
tea that's with only small tech model of
this coffee okay again and in this case
they you they use AV introduced atom in
domenase and with a guide RNA that is
specific that is underlined here that
you can see here and they they said they
obtained the on nails on may founder of
course they were really happy to obtain
on this model that was a mutation that
we wanted to correct the mutation okay
they obtained whereas the animal at the
beginning was a knockout they could
observe this very little that some cells
muscular cells our gain expressing the
distortion that looks great but of
course if the concern is not complete
you can also generate deletion and it
can still go back into the frame and
generate or just something that is
almost normal
anyways I said that works really well
again it's unloaded that hangs on the
exclusion because it's simpler and
because you need to target only one
allele in the mail and that's why this
kind of model is often present it
because it's the simplest model possible
so we decided just to go and test he'd
believe it oh she didn't believe it all
and on the tail on chosen eyes and I
will show you one and two version of
this raises it obeys those three and by
the little for and that's what we do
here we use this paper here you have the
reference is a nature by biotechnology
paper and you could see that such su
approach that they need for chavalla
nails what they wanted is to generate a
stop codon
Theoden eyes if you take imaginaries you
should have animals that are good black
animal if you walk on black seeds animal
but they go white if you target both
honey okay then basil Ito it goes from a
C to G by generating a stop codon again
I
Zhu Zhu Zhu was published editing window
and then we took the same guide RNA
generate heat
the irony of sorry first I'll show you
what they should and they show that
indeed they using observed obtained T so
incorrect but you can already see here
that so mutations are not the ones that
I expected okay and that there is no to
see but it's transformed to an G in the
paper and and sometimes you can see also
in the t11 too that you can have in this
which is not great if you think you
would do you would use that for therapy
I think and they say okay we know Marie
oh they say they see that animals are
have white eyes and that they should be
okay that's fine and what is even more
surprising is the conclusion saying that
you can in need this approach would be
useful to introduce single amino acid
substitution and correct genetic defect
in human embryos in the future which is
surprising because when you see what you
observe at the top I think you see
something that is not very specific and
that didn't see didn't look so much more
specific than normal crystal test night
so what we did we order from a gene the
plasmid couldn't form from very 3v3
cytidine deaminase version 3 and sitting
in the NL version for that were
published one in 2017 Nature
Biotechnology user in 2018 not in 2008
in the unit tests that in vitro they
don't just test is that on cells but it
was published and they say is beta 2 4
is better than to belittle 3 the third
action and that's what we did then we
didn't go until generation it is animals
or 3 our region but we generated
together the guide RNA the RNA for beta
2 3 ready T we obtained first animal
cells and after what we obtained when we
analyzed blasto sites
no such just on
on a mess and when we analyze these
animals you could see clearly on these
animals that it's really surprising
because I put the correct modification
expected modification in green and all
the other modifications are in red and
that is definitely not very specific
then it's a little frightening to see
that and that I think I wouldn't trust
that to do genetic therapy but that's a
benefit of free version I know we can go
and see what you look tank with a basal
Ito for versions that still taking
blastocyte only not generating animals
and you can see here that it looks a
little bit more specific but still even
if the cast iron was Nick Nicholson
we can still see delation than in the
first paper the first published in
nature biotech and we can still visit
the editing window is much larger than
what we is supposed to be then I think
for therapy we are still not there but
even more than the conclusion for this
experiment is that definitely involves
even if it works it is not great I mean
we see with one with seconds we could
see the conversion the expected
conversion see to change but we could
observe also C to a and C to G
conversion in most of the mutant
blastocyte we could observe deletions
insertions also in some blasto sites
since that's no good the editing window
is much much larger than what is present
ourselves even if it says it's not
precise here it's 10 base pair then to
generate a specific mutation it will be
very difficult and what is more annoying
is that again the animals are really
very mosaic we see many aliens 2 to 3
which is not better than what you
obtained with donor single donor DNA in
which we can really only introduce a
mutation we want and select for it then
what I address here is that perhaps we
could have mutated the gas 9 to dead
Cassadine and perhaps we wouldn't see in
this but that we want test again
because honestly I'm not convinced that
busy cheating is a future of crystal
cast 9 for the moment it still needs to
be more precise and be ameliorated at
the moment okay that's all for
babysitting and all is to finish I want
to show you and showed you already one
example about crystal cast 9 in most yes
cells because we knew Swiss focus 9 also
a lot Mouse's cells and that's to
generate very complicated complex allele
because it's complex solid I told you
are very difficult to obtain by your eye
microinjection into eggs that's why we
still use monkey cells and that's all
that does is just to show you all the
project number 3 of 1 to 23 and here you
can see that the number of clones that
we analyzed first and some this product
are we old and that's why when crystal
came out the sootopolis we didn't manage
to obtain one p1 for example two
products we we analyzed more than a
thousand five hundred shown without any
positive proton and then I just decided
to use the same time which in
concentrate putting one guide generating
a double strand double strand break and
the side of in insertion at the sides of
inception of the new and you can see
here the number of positive clones that
you obtain it's really a lot and it is
quite amazing how a simple guide RNA
whiskas name can change the number of
positive clone be obtained and that's
definitely really important it was
efficient we needed with linearized
construct with long and short arm for
the same construct it was very very
efficient then that also means with
Crispo
we don't need when he targeted cells to
clone big large over og arm but you can
use short or gm5 on with base pair is
more than sufficient that's very nice
what we observe and that's what we
always still do thousand lot to really
check we have self competi mirrors in a
lot of disciplines even if we manage to
get easily what
what you have got that emails and that's
something I'm trying to explain here is
even if you have a motor boots for
combinations that occurs on both side we
have more than one copy that he inserted
at the locus even if the 5-prime normal
runs PCR and the 3-prime no Mohnish pcr
is fine in the middle it's not correct
this means that we if you use an
internal probe you see we will see more
than one bond and that's again what I
want to say I again show my little
elephant with the blind man you really
need to check what you obtain when you
do when you use crystal be aware that
you can observe sometimes some strange
things and check that everything is fine
and that's an example because of course
complicating model are feasible easily
with whisper but share its order that we
have generated and that's even larger
than it's possible to do humanization
pretty easily using yourself simply and
that's the water we have generating in
fact we model with the three mutations
that you can see in green blue and
unread I put every 384 and upon ye 0.32
and four okay with the different
mutations here and the how we proceeded
for that we worked with the which gene
Brigitte for the construct they inserted
everything that is on the square here
from a bad human but they cloned
homology arms around I show you the
construct here I don't know if you can
see it well everything that is in blue
on the constructions circular construct
here is human and you can see in green
the emoji arms and they are here and we
cloned at ICS plasmid with a guide with
two guide RNAs that were located at the
size of the insertion we want t to to do
and when we perform the operations
that's what we obtained we really
obtained a lot of positive clones doing
long runs PCR once on five time or three
prime this means that we'll go through
donation walked well and that actually
also work
well if he used only a selection
pressure because in the targeting
construct we are the sex to selection
marker one hydro selection marker that
was for five framing session and one leo
selection marker for the three primary
combination and the using a selection
leo hydro or now why do we obtain
positive prawns and sometimes of course
also things is they must contact emails
I was talking about just before and just
to say that's how we validated our lines
after once we use the new probe and the
probe you could see that you in most of
the cases we had only one bond which is
nice we you can see that in thousands
that's why I want to show you your blood
that you with a little arrow you can see
the expected bond but also what is
sometimes disturbing when you worked
with CRISPR on yourself and you do a
thousand you can also see that the white
I believe can move because you can
delete completely the white type Alamelu
and you can generate the deletion of the
whole path on the other allele even if
the target that is correct but as when
we see the correct target Italian we
don't care about the white high poly and
that's very important also when you
analyze etc that issues from CRISPR has
nine electroporation then we confirm
that the humanization was correct
everything is there
we do a nice ap top 40 and ABC because
it's what our collaborator wanted to
have and I have to say with to the three
version of April we obtain German
transmission without any problems and it
was pretty easy and even if you used it
ourselves in the year we obtained the
three lines and it's not so easy to
obtain that through CRISPR when we
obtained lines and that's just a review
you can go and have a look at all you
will wrote here but just to say that
it's supposed to work with back plasmids
because it was published in Nature
communication in 2016 they show
different ways to obtain domination
humanization but that worked only in
right
I don't know why but I think a lot of
people tried to obtain the same approach
you using your back weasel to guys and
as they call this so two hits to go or
three hits two illegals they tried this
approach you can go and see if I won't
go into the detail of this experiment it
seemed to working but in rat first
because of the eggs the rat eggs are
more resistant but when you go into the
the mouse it doesn't seem to work so
well and then in theory gusto
combination in yourself allows us to
obtain the same kind of thing in more or
less the same time perhaps a little
longer but at least we can validate
everything very well in yourself whereas
you cannot do that if you obtain
directly and mice and can you have to
breed animals then as I told you let's
just speak about kind of humanization we
can obtain that can also address a
question what is the best humanization
that we it's it's video question we can
lo Andres because we have Chris focus 9
he is doing production of specific code
a mutation a better model than the whole
chain immunization
know we can humanize your whole gene
then what is a bad best water what do we
have to humanize those who do we have to
keep the human regulatory sequence or
just replace from the ATG to the stop
that's also a question we can address
that is it's really important to keep
all the human intron or is it better to
use a cDNA for trustful source for the
expression of the gene because when you
put human intron will they behave the
same than in in rat that's really
question you can ask yourself and also
argue when I put in interacting as
efficiently with the hood on contraband
because you need to good ID to humanize
a whole gene and put it in a rat or
Mouse I mean sometimes you can imagine
that as they don't have the real
instructors and perhaps it won't work as
well but anyway this is a question I
like to to ask to people and so nice way
to to think about it okay at least we
can do everything
I think everything is new
possible with whisper it really has
rendered everything quite easy to obtain
and how far can we go with whisper of
course there is still a lot of space for
improvement there are improved test 9
variant I have to say too haven't tried
them so much because caffeine works so
well in embryos that it's not really
worth it and also what I wanted to
emphasize here we are not caring so much
when we work on animals about off
targets because we go through mitosis
and meiosis is a wonderful with shuffle
of all the genes whereas if you work on
you in cell lines you will never get rid
of targets that's why people working on
animals and not caring so much because
when you generate your line you breed
your founders and you will segregate you
off targets if it's fair enough
genetically that's really why we younger
so much in to studying the different
variant but there are alternative
protein CPS 1 2 P 2 and that Siskin can
be interesting we would like to minimize
mosaicism that still problem even miss
the editing and show you that very
clearly would that reduce of targets
then perhaps we could we could decide to
to those amount of past 9 now sometimes
when it's too efficient perhaps to get
less advanced will get a non-real tool
to give both born put pups instead of
putting too much cast 9 and generation
just dead on view and of course there
are people working on inhibitor of
inertia J modulator and so there are
many things many teams that are working
the way to improve christa last night ok
and though to almost finalized what I
want to say crystal cast iron is great I
showed you that but I think you need to
really think carefully at least at our
place what you need to what you want to
do I put a scale so timing months and
you need just to realize that the time
to fully validate an allele when you are
working with yourselves it takes the
time of the cell growing and you can do
can't your pc on your clothes
check that everything is correct and we
spend your time validating everything in
yourselves and only inject one clone
that is really perfect and it's really
great when you do be blamed when you're
stationed larger education whereas when
you use CRISPR you can go fast you will
obtain very fast very quickly a funder
even German but after remember my little
elephants
you still need to really validate that
everything is perfectly fine I think
it's really important to keep in mind
that even if crystal looks really simple
everybody wants it to be really simple
it is simple it is great wonderful but
you really need to validate carefully
the lines that you are generating in
order to make sure that you are not
following something that is not
effective and finally just to thank all
the people that's my lab in which we do
more or less also Chris caucus 9 work is
two people home and Lauren's Laura and
Bella Hibbs and the people that do
AutoCAD East and Asia I want to thank
you by Louie Louie girl in there mainly
and all the people that are involved yes
cell culture because they do and reach a
greater ESL walk among Latino fiance and
a Zama Ironman and those people from the
microinjection and also responsible for
from phenomenal yes and thank you very
much I will be happy to answer your
question and I hope I was clear enough
thank you thank you dr. Berlin for that
informative presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder dr. Berlin
will follow up with any questions you
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye